California man died at University  Medical Center after he was injured in a  jet ski accident on the Arizona side of  the Colorado River Authorities say he  was one of four people injured Monday in  Bullhead City after getting struck by a  rented jet ski that a 26 year old Las  Vegas woman was operating a 21-year-old  Las Vegas man remains hospitalized in  Nevada while two other victims were  treated and released that's just one of  several boating accidents around our  regional Lakes over the holiday weekend  on Lake Havasu authorities say a man  fell off a personal watercraft and wound  up swimming for 30 minutes before he was  picked up by a passing boater there were  also instances of people jumping off  boats to go for a swim and the boat  starting to float away all in all 59  citations were issued 15 people were  arrested for reckless operation of a  watercraft and two people were arrested  for operating Under the Influence in  Mojave County